У Лесі температура і нежить.
Ой, лишенько, невже грип?
Треба йти до лікаря.
Згідно з медичною реформою, в ідеалі все мало би виглядати так:
Леся сама вирішує, якого сімейного лікаря чи терапевта їй обрати,
і йде до лікаря з чудовими відгуками майже поруч з домом.
На першому прийомі Леся має підписати з лікарем
договір про надання медичних послуг.
Для укладення договору потрібні паспорт,
ідентифікаційний номер і мобільний телефон.
Готово!
Договір підписується безстроково
і діє доти, поки Леся не захоче змінити лікаря.
Жодних реєстраційних талонів більше не потрібно.
Паперові медкартки поступово замінять на електронні -
медицина впродовж трьох років має перейти в онлайн.
Саме сімейний лікар надає первинну медичну допомогу -
обстежує, призначає аналізи і дає направлення до профільних спеціалістів.
акцинація, медичні довідки, лікарняні, рецепти -
це все теж до сімейного лікаря.
Для попередньої консультації Леся може просто зателефонувати лікареві.
Таких пацієнтів, як Леся, у лікаря може бути не більше двох тисяч на рік.
Тож не варто чекати, поки захворієте,
краще підписати договір заздалегідь.
На кожного пацієнта сімейний лікар отримуватиме гроші від держави:
по 370 гривень на рік на дорослого
і 740 - на дитину чи пенсіонера.
Лесі натомість платити лікарю нічого не треба -
вона вже сплатила до держбюджету податки.
Моніторитиме все Національна служба здоров'я.
А якщо у Лесі несподівано прихопило серце
і треба викликати швидку?
Лікування випадків, які загрожують життю, теж 100% фінансуватиме держава.
Це стосується також лікування дітей до 14 років,
супроводу вагітних та пологів,
а також паліативної допомоги.
Крім того, держава - повністю або частково -
оплачуватиме Лесі ліки, якщо вони входять
до Нацпереліку або програми "Доступні ліки".
Для цього Лесі потрібно просто показати в аптеці рецепт від лікаря.
А гроші аптеці відшкодують з держбюджету.
Первинна медицина - це перший етап медичної реформи.
На наступних ітиметься про профільних лікарів,
лікарні, операції та інші послуги
вторинного рівня медобслуговування.
Але буде це не раніше 2020 року.
Останнє, але вкрай важливе:
Лесю, давати хабарі більше не треба!
Якщо лікар вимагає гроші,
дзвоніть на гарячу лінію у Національній службі здоров’я.
Така ось теорія. А на практиці?
Як ви гадаєте, чи запрацює медреформа у вашому місті?